it's no secret that Katy Perry and  Taylor Swift have a long-standing feud  then they don't fix bullet holes but  Katie admits she's open to working with  T Swift under one condition she wants an  apology what a fantastic surprise the  rise singer took to Twitter Saturday to  answer fan questions hinting that she  would be open to making music with her  former friend the user tweeted will you  collab with Taylor Swift prompting Perry  to write if she says sorry sure the duo  has been feuding since 2014 when Swift  claimed her hit song bad blood was about  an unknown celebrity pal who turned on  her while we would be thrilled to see  the two entertainers reunite taylor has  yet to speak out about the firework  hitmakers tweet et has reached out to  Katie's camp for comment  you